مساعده غربيه من الارض والفضاء اقمار
ستارلينج للانترنت خدمه الملياردير
الامريكي الى الماسك ليكيف اداء سيرلانك
في اوكرانيا اشعل سباقا فضائيا جديدا كما
تقول مجله
الاقمار الصناعيه في مدار ارضي منخفضه
يمكنه توصيل الانترنت فائق السرعه الى اي
مكان في العالم ساهم النظام في دعم
اوكرانيا عسكريه وبحسب فان هذه الخدمه
وفرت نوعا من الرشاقه التكتيكيه الحيويه
للحرب الحديثه من جهه وقاومت هجمات
التشويش والاختراق من جهه اخرى الشهر
الماضي اعلنت روسي عن رادار للكشف عن
اجهزه ستار لينك على مسافه 10 كيلو مترات
بدقه 60 مترا وفي نوفمبر الماضي كشفت ايضا
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن مسيره جديده
قادره على تعطيل محطات اتصال
تقول مجله الكراميست ان روسيا والصين
تحاولان التوصل الى التكنولوجيا لمواجهه
يوم مهاجمه استرلينج وتعطيلها اذا دعت
الحاجه غير ان شركه سبيس اكس تواصلوا
ارسال اقمارها الصناعيه في مجال يشهد
منافسه شديدا اسيما في امريكا واوروبا
والصين ايضا في شركه جالاكسي سبيس صينيه
اطلقت مارس الماضي صاروخا يحمل سته اقمار
صناعيه في ما تخطط لاطلاق نحو الف قمر
صناعي